- [Voiceover] What I
wanna do in this video
is compare the fractions 3/4
and 4/5,
and I wanna do this visually.
So what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna have two copies
of the same whole, so
let me just draw that,
but I'm gonna divide the first one,
so this is one whole right
over here, this rectangle,
when we draw the whole thing.
So this is a whole,
and right below that,
we have the same whole.
We have a rectangle of
exactly the same size.
Now you might notice
that I've divided them
into a different number of equal sections.
In the top one, I've divided
it into four equal sections
because I am concerned with fourths
so I've divided this
top whole into fourths
and I've divided this bottom
whole, or this bottom bar
or this bottom rectangle, into fifths,
or five equal sections.
So let's think about what 3/4 represent.
So that's gonna be one of
the fourths, right over here,
two of the fourths,
and then three of the fourths.
And what is 4/5 going to be?
Well, 4/5 is going to be one fifth,
two fifths,
three fifths, and four fifths.
So when you look at
them visually, remember,
we're taking fractions of the same whole.
This is 3/4 of that rectangle,
this is 4/5 of a same-sized rectangle.
It wouldn't make any
sense if you're doing it
for different shapes or
different sized rectangles.
We just divided them
into different sections
and you see that if you
have four of the fifths,
that that is going to be more
than three of the fourths,
and so 4/5 is greater than 3/4
or you could say 3/4 is less than 4/5,
or any way you wanna think about it.
The symbol you wanna use always
opens to the larger number.
4/5 is larger than 3/4,
so the large end of our
symbol is facing the 4/5,
so we would say 3/4 is less than 4/5.